let's start with the president
practicing the art of the deal even
while on vacation
he gave Democrats his bottom line for
any daca deal on amnesty for the illegal
immigrants called dreamers the president
tweeted today quote the Democrats have
been told and fully understand that
there can be no daca without the
desperately needed wall at the southern
border and an end to the horrible chain
migration and ridiculous lottery systems
of immigration etc we must protect our
country at all costs can the president
get the Democrats to guess and will his
own base accept amnesty let's discuss
that with Fox News contributor Steve
Cortez a former Trump campaign operative
and spokesman for the Hispanic 100 and
Steven wall Roy a law professor at the
University of Memphis and a former
federal prosecutor happy new year
gentlemen thank you for a year for
joining us this is going to be a
contentious issue as we turned it to the
March 5th deadline that is out there on
daca professor I want to start with you
you know my concern is that Democrats
they like the issue they just don't
actually want to solve it they always
say oh we need comprehensive we need to
do all these things the president's
asked is pretty simple let's build the
wall it's something that Democrats have
supported in the past is it unreasonable
to think that we should protect our
border and build a wall well it's not
unreasonable to think that we should
protect our border but we don't
necessarily need to build a wall in
order to do that I mean the actual wall
itself it were to cover the exact
complete expanse of the border would
cost tens of billions of dollars and
would probably not even be effective
because what sections of wall we already
have experience has shown that you can
tunnel under them or put ramps or
ladders over them so if you're going to
be spending tens of billions of dollars
on a wall that actually won't work and
we'll simply alienate relations with
Mexico why not use that money in a
better way by increasing border security
agents and doing economic developments
in Mexico to reduce the demand for
illegal immigration increased guest
worker programs there are a lot more
efficient efficacious ways of tackling
this problem that would
not alienate Mexico would actually work
and would be a better use of our tax
dollars well Steve Cortez the the
president's gonna get is his wall isn't
he he's gonna get the 1.8 billion
dollars that he wanted I don't know how
he could settle for anything less as
President Obama said elections have
consequences right and this is one of
the things the president promised he was
going to do
they sure do and then Jason this was a
pillar of his electoral mandate and I
called him president promise keeper
because what he did in 2017 is keep one
promise after another we are going to
get that wall and by the way the walls
not just good for the United States I
would disagree with the professor it's
also actually good for Mexico because it
has a problem on its southern border
largely because of our poorest southern
border so getting our border under
control between Texas and Arizona and
California and Mexico is good policies
often good good neighbors need good
fences and that's what we need between
the US and Mexico but more importantly I
really want to give the president so
much credit for what he's already done
even before the big beautiful wall goes
up illegal crossings have plunged under
this president why because of clear-eyed
rhetoric and better enforcement and
don't take my word for it by the way the
director of ice Tom Holman said that
this president has done more for border
security than the six previous
presidents combined so he is already
enhancing our economic and national
security by securing our borders now
professor you gotta admit that the
numbers are reflective on the reduction
of the border crossing but they're still
happening what do you attribute that the
lower a crossing rate to be other than
the election of Donald Trump it's
important to remember that actually
immigration border crossings were
actually on the decline four years prior
to the election of Donald Trump we
actually now have a negative net outflow
of immigration there are more people
leaving than coming in and that was the
case well before Donald Trump was
elected and as to whether he I gotta
tell you I was a chairman of a committee
in Congress and we held multiple
hearings i could not i don't i would
love to see those numbers where you
think that we were actually on the
decline with with president obama i mean
that
siloam seekers others that were coming
across this border were much higher than
they are today well you know the source
that I would use right now would be
politifact which actually did a recent
study a few months ago on this very
thing but as to the politics of it let's
also remember that President Trump had
previously agreed with Chuck Schumer
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi to give them
daca reform in exchange for beefed up
border security without the wall why
would it make sense for them to now
negotiate against themselves and go
backwards as part of the negotiations
between the White House and Capitol Hill
but professor you'd be okay if it's not
necessarily a physical wall but if it
went to border security I would probably
personally disagree with you that
economic development and northern Mexico
is I don't know why the Americans have
to pay for that but what else
so you'd be okay right professor if it
was not just the wall but border
security and definition of that we might
want to haggle about correct right well
I think that actually increased border
security and increased guest worker
program would be a more efficient use of
our tax dollars than actually building a
wall which I think will be way more
expensive than we expect because of the
land rights that we would have to buy
through eminent domain and the fact that
it's not really very effective so I
think it makes sense to talk about
border security and daca reform without
the wall so Steve Cortes what what else
is the president going to have to get
because there is a long laundry list the
lottery asylum reform there's daca what
what else do you think is imperative
you've been close to Donald Trump what
do you think is imperative now Jason and
here's what I think is on the way and
here's what I've told the president
personally and I disagree with some of
my colleagues on Team Trump people whom
I respect I do believe the daca
recipients and they're not dreamers by
the way I don't call them dreamers
Americans have dreams too and they're
not kids they are adults but I believe
dr. recipients are a different category
of illegal immigrant those who truly did
not choose to come here as because they
were brought here as children so I
believe they should be protected and
again I disagree with a lot of people I
respect on that issue but having said
that and this is what I've told the
president I believe what he will do is
we need things in return and the big
things are borders secured
more barricades more resources for the
border but also we can't just stop there
and end to chain migration chain
migration has been a disaster for the
United States it affronts our national
security it affronts our economic
security right now and I'm the son of an
immigrant and an Hispanic the majority
of immigrant headed households in the
United States receive some form of
welfare that's a tragedy that's terrible
policy and it's nothing like our parents
and grandparents and great-grandparents
faced when they came here when they
wanted nothing from the United States
other than an opportunity so we're not
going immigration right largely because
of chain migration that has to end so we
have to have a grand bargain which I do
believe is going to happen in in January
daca recipients protected and to chain
migration resources of the border
gentlemen thank you a Happy New Year
appreciate you joining us in this
conversation earlier on Fox News Senator
Lindsey Graham came on and said there
was no possible way that we're gonna do
daca by itself that that was just
political theater it'll be interesting
to see how it plays out starting in
January